in the meantime lawmakers in the u.s.
have voted to move forward with
investigative procedures that could lead
to impeachment hearings on President
Donald Trump the committee voted along
party lines approved over unanimous
Republican opposition but will now allow
the enhanced questioning of witnesses
the first step in a very lengthy process
that could eventually lead to an
impeachment here this committee is
engaged in an investigation that will
allow us to determine whether to
recommend articles of impeachment with
respect to president Trump that is what
we are doing some call this process and
impeachment inquiry some qualitative
Pietschmann investigation there's no
legal difference between these terms and
I no longer care to argue about the
nomenclature we'll get some analysis on
this in a moment first Mike Hanna a
correspondent in Washington has more the
House Judiciary Committee has passed a
resolution specifying the investigative
procedures that could lead at some stage
to the impeachment of President Trump
now it's agreed on a series of measures
such as enhanced questioning of
witnesses staffers would be allowed to
question a witness for one hour after
the members have completed their
questioning it also provides for the
establishment of secret committees to
hear evidence and of course the
establishment of subcommittees to hear
evidence now the one caveat all of this
and this pointed out by Republicans on
the committee who voted against it that
these rules were already in place or
that the Chairman had the power to
impose these rules Republicans using
that as evidence that this is nothing
more than political grandstanding and
attempt to keep the issue or the word
impeachment within the public debate
nonetheless these investigative measures
will be in place when the formal Trump
chief of staff campaign staff gives
evidence before the committee next week
now he's likely to be questioned by
staffers after committee members have
finished their questioning this will be
the first test of the rules that are now
in place which Republicans
master repeat say have always been in
place anyway with us on skype now Joel
Rubin who is president of the Washington
Strategy Group security and foreign
policy strategic advisory Joe there's a
lot of you know could happen might lead
to starting down the path fear with all
that in mind how do you sort of
categorize today's developments how big
how significant you're right this is a
could and maybe will occur moment but
certainly from a house Democratic
perspective it's a significant break
from where Democrats have been up until
this point over the summer and it's
important to know this over the summer
the majority of House Democrats came on
board with the idea of impeachment so
right now in the House chamber the
Democrats are in support of it so this
process enables a more robust and
intrusive investigation to occur towards
potentially bad end but how do you do
that when I say you I mean these
Democrats have come on board how do they
do that when their leader
Nancy Pelosi has been quite opposed to
the whole idea if she said it publicly
in fact that she doesn't think they
should go down the impeachment road yes
speaker Pelosi has been the one who is
kind of tempered this because she
understands that still in poll after
poll the majority of Americans did not
support a full impeachment but Democrats
and Democratic voters do by two-thirds
in terms of the latest polling so that
means that she's in a bind and she wants
to see what comes out so she is pushed
the process but not killed it if
something comes out in these hearings in
these discussions over the next month or
two that really changes the public mood
then demonstrates that there is more
there that can be used politically
that's our ultimate calculus politically
for the house to not only move on
impeachment but then force it into the
Senate that will tip her scales in
junking it but right now she's not there
I'm glad you mentioned the Senate
because that's the point I always come
back to what's the point if the Senate
is controlled by the Republicans
it's never gonna get through there yeah
there are several different points at
the core the majority of the house
members that say they support
impeachment say they do because they
believe that the president has violated
the Constitution and committed eye
crimes it needs to be held accountable
and they're not concerned about the idea
that he won't be convicted in the Senate
which means removal from office on a
political level many Democrats are
saying that if the president's impeached
in the house and the vote goes to the
Senate vulnerable Republicans will have
to then go on record in supporting the
president or not and if they do it will
help the Senate Democrats take back the
Senate in 2020 so there's a lot of that
underway right now nobody this one
appoints the Senate will actually
convicted president if he's impeached by
the house one final thing I want you to
clear up just for our international
viewers and that is seems strange to ask
this now but in the United States what
impeachment actually is because in other
parts of the world if you're impeach
then you're gone that's not quite the
case in the u.s. is it yes yes thank you
it's a bicameral system meaning we have
two chambers of Congress so the house
has the duty to conduct an inquiry and
investigation and then impeach and if
they do which means the majority
supports removal from office that then
gets referred to the Senate who then
does a trial where the Supreme Court
Chief Justice goes and conducts a trial
and the Senate then chooses whether or
not to convict that the impeachment
process the president was impeached and
at that stage please removed from office
they vote down and in the case of
President Clinton the Senate voted to
not remove him from office not convict
then the president stays in office even
though he was technically engaged by the
house represented important thing to
clear up isn't it thank you for all of
that Joel Rubin in Washington
Thanks